côté diplomatique à bruxelles les
ministres des affaires étrangères et de
défense de l'union européenne sont
réunis pour examiner de nouvelles
sanctions contre moscou les européens
devrait aussi approuver la constitution
d'une force de 5000 combattants et
s'engager sur une augmentation des
dépenses militaires on attend d'ailleurs
une allocution du chef de la diplomatie
européenne josep borrell probablement
dans une demi heure on retrouve tout de
suite à bruxelles notre correspondante à
l'x le bourdon alix bonsoir les
européens sont encore divisés sur cette
question des sanctions
bien en effet un la prochaine étape dans
les sanctions contre la russie serait
celle d'un embargo énergétique mais sur
cette question il n'y a en effet pas de
consensus entre les vingt-sept il ya en
fait deux grands courants de pensée d'un
côté ceux qui veulent temporiser un
comme l'allemagne qui met en garde
contre une décision précipitée alors que
les prix de l'énergie sont déjà très
élevés et puis de l'autre côté il ya
ceux majoritairement les pays de l'est
qui pensent au contraire qu'il faut
prendre ce cinquième train de sanctions
est visé le secteur de l'énergie est
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui à leur arrivée à
bruxelles plusieurs ministres ont plaidé
en faveur de ce genre de mesures la
pologne a même appelé à un embargo total
sur le commerce avec la russie un
d'autres ministres comme le ministre
irlandais ont avancé l'idée d'un embargo
énergétique mais tu ne toucherait que le
pétrole et le charbon alors l'idée bien
sûr et bien c'est de ne pas trop
pénaliser l'europe qui vous le savez est
dépendante à plus de 40% du gaz russe
mais seulement 20 % du pétrole et puis
il ya aussi le fait qu'il est plus
facile d'un point de vue logistique de
trouver d'autres fournisseurs de pétrole
tout simplement puisque contrairement au
gaz le pétrole est liquidé il peut donc
être acheminés tout simplement par
bateaux alors difficile de dire si ce
soir un les européens vont prendre une
décision il l'a laisseront sans doute
plus sur la table des 27 chefs d'état et
de gouvernement qui se réunissent ce
jeudi à bruxelles en sommet merci alix
alex le bourdon diact de bruce